e aí
eu estou muito feliz
eu nasci aqui no rio de janeiro filha de
um homem camelô muito empreendedor mas
que tinha um conceito que para ser
respeitado na vida a gente tem que ter
dinheiro
oi gente uma mulher incrível para ela
não tinha tempo ruim você tava sol tá
bom você tá chovendo o que maravilha mas
tinha que ter solução para todos os
problemas não vou de olhar para o
problema e sim para solução dele
tô morando aqui no rio de janeiro
trabalhando de camelô da família na
baixada fluminense saímos daqui para uma
vida melhor e fomos para lá no espírito
santo
a cidade nos acolheu e ali nós começamos
trabalhar de camelô com esse conceito do
meu pai de que para ser respeitado tinha
que ter dinheiro
e eu pareço da muito cedo e fui tomar
conta da barraca ele teve uma morte
muito precoce e eu tive que ajudar minha
mãe no sustento da família na barraca
trabalhando na barraca de camelô a gente
percebe os as dificuldades que tem disse
colocar na cidade é
eu tinha tantas discussões e muitas
vezes brigas com o poder público é para
dizer aqui não pode aqui não pode ver o
rappa sai correndo aquela coisa que
vocês conhecem no dia a dia de qualquer
sociedade mas começou nessas brigas me
gerar um sentimento e o sentimento que
eu não conseguia saber muito bem o nome
dele
é mas eu sempre tava na discussão e
falando e brigando e dizendo aqui não dá
porque eu ficava indignada quando poder
público pensava no poste na lixeira no
fio até na pedrinha portuguesa mas não
pensava naquelas famílias que estavam
ali
oi e um dia uma faculdade ali da cidade
resolveu fazer um grupo de estudante de
direito resolveu fazer um documentário e
eles deram de barraca e barraca
perguntando quem é que podia falar e os
camelôs falava se a gente não fala não
não gosto de câmera não mas procura
jaqueline e eles começaram a me apontar
e aí eu vou lavar sim quê que vocês
estão querendo então precisando a gente
quer fazer um documentário sobre a
marginalização do trabalho informal aí
eu disse assim nossa marginalização foi
aí que eu consegui dar o nome aquele
sentimento que eu tinha 10
bom dia aproximadamente 15 anos quando
eu tiver minha primeira barraca era mais
finalização eu não era marginal dali a
gente da barraca a gente fez uma casinha
mesmo de dar barraca nós compramos um
carrinho usado tivemos a nossa primeira
casa própria lá numa comunidade humilde
do espírito santo não éramos marginais
mas eu gostei tanto daquilo que eu falei
assim eu quero fazer isso eu fui lá fiz
a filmagem fui na apresentação e foi
muito legal porque quando os estudantes
apresentaram ele me convidaram para
estar lá na faculdade e quando eu
cheguei lá e vi a minha história na tela
eu fiquei impressionada e me pedindo
para dar uma palavra no final professora
me abraçou e falou bem assim menina você
fala tão bem você precisa fazer direito
aí ela falou uma semente no meu coração
sem saber e aí eu falei assim beleza mas
eu só tinha 5ª série do ensino
fundamental eu falei opa vou me
matricular no lá e já me matriculei uma
extra trabalhando na barraca levava
apostila para lá para escola estudava na
barraca fazer a
o e levei um bom tempo para terminar o
meu estudo da 5ª a 8ª
eu consegui terminar
e nessa nessa nessa que eu já tava até
me casando mudei para um bairro já na
eja do ensino médio quando eu cheguei
nesse bairro
é mas o incômodo aí já não era mais o
incômodo com camelô já era um encontro
com meu bairro tinha mais de trinta e
seis ruas no bairro só uma pavimentada e
eu tava fazendo a eja do ensino médio e
aí eu subia na poeira desse na lama
tinha até um apelido ela escorrega ela
vai um porque quando a gente descia o
morro escorrega ela vai um quando não
botava sacola na no pé para não sujar
porque tinha muito barro e aí mais uma
vez eu indignada com aquela situação
tinha que estudar tinha que chegar tarde
e aí eu fui um dia numa escola numa
reunião de pais da minha filha nesse
bairro eu tava moradora nova e nessa
reunião de pais eu falei assim vamos
fazer um mutirão já que o problema é
esse eu fiz uma proposta de fazer um
mutirão na escola e aí todo mundo gostou
da ideia demorou uns dez dias mais ou
menos a diretora me liga e falou bem
assim jaqueline você pode vir aqui na
escola posso
o que é eu tenho uma eleição aqui de
representante de pais e você foi eleita
e o nosso mas eu nem me candidatei aí
ela falou bem assim é você for teve mais
voto aí eu falei assim poxa que bom
então tá bom né aí eu percebi que aquela
comunidade também precisava de uma voz e
aí alguém começou a falar e a iva já que
você é linda dos pais porque que a gente
não gente faz reunião mas nós vamos
fazer um negócio tem uma associação de
moradores desse bairro a tem uma
associação mas não funciona vamos fazer
um grupo de resgate fizemos um grupo de
resgate resgatamos associação e daqui a
pouco fizemos uma eleição e quem foi
eleita a jaqueline líder comunitário
sabia nem que que era isso líder
comunitário do bairro mas eu comecei a
trabalhar no bairro e um dia eu chego em
casa
o time velop branco desse tamanho
escrito congresso nacional
e a jaqueline moraes da silva presidente
da associação de moradores gente com que
esse povo me achou aqui no bairro
operário fiquei um pouco impressionada
não sabia como funcionava direito mas
eles têm todos os controles de quem
ganha líder comunitário e tal sabe né as
coisas e eu fui para ufes universidade
federal do espírito santo participar de
uma palestra que tinha um ministro de
infraestrutura o menino falava assim
vocês que são prefeito vocês que são
líder comunitário tem que cobrar os
projetos porque brasília tem dinheiro
mas as prefeituras não têm projeto então
líder cobre o projeto e eu falei venceu
anotando tudo na cadê netinha cheguei lá
no meu baixo a 6 diretoria para gente
tem que ir até o prefeito fomos até o
prefeito com muitas idas e vindas
conseguimos fazer a ideia de um prefeito
levar o projeto para lá para resumir
teve dois projetos pilotos em brasília
escolhendo para lançar lá no estado de
espírito santo e um dos dois bairros foi
o meu o bairro operário que teve oitenta
por cento das ruas tá
o início já andava no bairro como assim
as pessoas então se você tem que se
candidatar e eu me candidatar a vereador
e foi a sexta mais votado da cidade
chega aí para vereadora e quando eu
cheguei lá para vereadora mais incômodo
eu e os incômodos a voz das mulheres
parece que não são ouvidas nos
parlamentos nos lugares principalmente
na política a voz das mulheres muitas
vezes são silenciados e as mulheres são
invisíveis e eu comecei a me incomodar
com aquilo e mais uma vez aquele em como
eu falei eu preciso trabalhar por
políticas públicas para as mulheres a
partir da língua você em novos voos eu
fui para um local no estado onde eu pude
trabalhar a participação das mulheres
empoderamento das mulheres no espaço de
poder e quando eu fui trabalhando isso
eu me deparei com uma situação
a trágica que é o que a tal das cotas
falava que tinha cota de mulheres e na
verdade a cota de gênero a lei diz que
tiver setenta por cento do gênero tem
que ter 30 do outro e aí eu falava
porque que nós mulheres não podemos ser
os 70 e não uns 30 eu comecei a falar
sobre isso e aí eu me deparei com coisa
muito pior quando você uma busca você
percebia muitas mulheres que nem ela
mesmo voltava nela é a tal chamada
candidatura laranja e aí eu queria uma
campanha chamada hashtag não seja
laranja para as mulheres não aceitasse
ou se submeter aquela situação de ser
laranja e aí nós começamos a falar isso
no estado eu comecei nos meios de
comunicação nas redes social e o que
aconteceu recebi o convite para ser a
vice-governadora do estado do espírito
santo eu aceitei o desafio fui para uma
candidatura e
e não é sério tem muitas mulheres
fazendo a diferença em algum lugar a
dona arlete uma vereadora lá em vila
velha ela não 70 anos líder comunitário
ela disse eu vou me candidatar ela
candidato ganhou que ela era uma voz
naquela comunidade
é a questão de gênero é tão importante
que a onu na sua agenda 2030 ela diz do
que o quinto objetivo sustentável do
milênio é a igualdade de gênero nos
poderes homens e mulheres equilíbrio a
onu defende isso tem duas michelis que
eu gosto muito a michelle obama e a
michele baixo e lê a michelle obama ela
diz assim eu trabalho pelo empoderamento
das mulheres por mais política para as
mulheres para que as minhas filhas vivam
no mundo onde a voz das mulheres tenham
mais força e michele baixo e lê-se ela
diz assim quando uma mulher entra na
política muda a mulher mas quando muitas
mulheres entram na política muda a
política e foi isso que eu comecei a
pensar mas mulheres mais
representatividade mais qualidade e
quantidade de política pública começamos
a trabalhar isso então hoje eu quero
dizer aqui que os incômodos
a não ser transformado no espaço de fala
no lugar de fala e onde estão seus
incômodos
e os seus incômodos eles estão bem
pertinho de você lá na comunidade que
você mora na escola do seu filho até no
posto de saúde do seu bairro o seu
incômodo ele pode estar no momento que
você muda o seu olhar para uma pessoa
com deficiência agora como transformar
esse incômodo no lugar de fala porque o
lugar de fala ele te projeta para algum
lugar hoje eu tô aqui no palco do tex
niterói ocupando o lugar de fala
tô escrevendo a história como a primeira
mulher não só apenas mulher mulher negra
e da periferia eleita vice-governadora
do estado do espírito santo para dizer
para você mulher ocupe o seu lugar de
fala e que você possa se apaixonar pela
política porque representatividade é
tudo obrigado a
a nossa a